welcome to what's gonna be a pretty
special video
in front of me I have the Chessa board
this is a smart chessboard
and I know a lot of you aren't used to
the third dimension but these are
physical chess pieces and this is
historically how chess has been played
over the board but up until recently
we've only seen like dumb wooden
chessboards but there's a lot of
underlying technology with this board
and the coolest thing is when you touch
a piece you don't even have to touch it
hard you just like tap it it will show
the legal moves for your side there's
actually a lot of a lot of features with
this there's different assistance modes
to get
um the best move this phrase will light
up different colors to show what the
best moves are but in this video I'm
going to try out a new feature that was
recently added in beta to the chess up
app and I'm going to try to play against
an online opponent on chess.com now this
has been possible uh for Leeches but I'm
excited to get another game on my speed
run account
and if you saw my previous video you'll
know that I recently set up an account
for a speedrun but I need to play a
certain number of games to get an
established rating before I can actually
start the speed run so I figured why not
kill a couple birds with one stone or
maybe one pawn and
um and yeah play a game on this board
try it out and hopefully uh punish some
beginner mistakes
do I dare play spell chess on this I
don't think so
uh let's let's play a normal game
so I will hit play
and I am playing Hamed matin 7 something
uh my speed run rating is 1183 I'm
whites let's at least no more time and I
will play my first move on e4
and I don't have to look at the app uh
actually because the opponent's moves
will light up I just have to make the
the moves for the opponents let's fight
another three
uh we're gonna stick with very basic
opening principles
won't do anything too fancy we see
classic Knight C6 and I think what I'll
do is play a ponziani because why not
one of the best beginner friendly
openings
can also be effective at higher levels
um D6 is already a slight inaccuracy
because it locks in this bishop
and I'll go ahead and play D4
taking over the center
now I do want to note that when you're
playing an online opponent there's no
assistance mode available so I can't
like cheat and uh and see what the best
moves are with uh
with the board all I can see is illegal
moves so when I touch the queen all the
squares all the legal squares will light
up where the queen can move
I should also note this is not touch
move even though I touched the queen I
don't have to move it the rules might be
different in uh internments so do be
aware
uh okay opponent pins me on
F3
but do I care let's just develop Let's
Play Bishop C4
there might be some cases where I'll
have to accept double pawns on the king
side
but um yeah we see takes
oh I can't take with knights
I want to do some tactics against F7
like I'm considering Queen B3 here
but
yeah Queen B3 Queen D7 I think it's way
more simple just to take the pawn
and this is usually the goal ponziani
you get two Pawns in the center
have very fluid development for the rest
of the pieces you see Knight F6
attacking my E4 Pawn
so
I think I'll just defend Knight C3
simple enough
trying to be very efficient with the
development of the minor pieces note
that every single minor piece I've only
moved once so far
finding trying to find the ideal squares
we do see takes
and this is an interesting moment
because if I take with the queen
then this d-pawn will hang
if I take with a pawn
I have
double pawns but I'm going for this
I actually play the game
on the same account not too long ago
that feature the strength of having
double pawns and we might see another
example of how double pawns can be very
strong
even though sometimes
they have a reputation of being weak I
think there might be two reasons here
why they can be a strength
for one this pawn and F3 reinforces upon
an E4
and secondly I have the G file which I
don't know if I'll be able to use so
soon
but maybe
maybe Queen B3
Queen B3 is one of these moves it looks
like a a simple tactic to win upon
but I don't think it's so simple like
Queen B3 now I can't draw arrows but I
can point Queen B3 Queen G7 take the
pawn Rook V8
I don't want to be too materialistic
I'm gonna go for a different plan I'm
gonna play Queen D2 I like my queen
staying in the center
D4 is now still very well defended
and I'm setting up the battery between
my queen and my Bishop
which could come into
to use very soon
and because I haven't committed casting
kingside
I'm not gonna Castle kingside
I can start pushing my H Pawn it's time
to attack
I have the center
I have a rook Stone H1
but this will be super interesting
because blocks King side formation is
very solid
um it might be hard to crack immediately
we see Asics
yeah A6 it's the type of move that
signifies maybe black doesn't quite know
what to do
hmm
maybe black wants to play B5
I think I'm okay allowing B5 though
now I think it's time to Castle
so I'm realizing
the one piece that really once again to
play is this Rook uh this Rook wants to
come to G1 eventually
uh but first things first let's save the
bishop
and Bishop D5 is interesting Bishop B3
I think I'll play Bishop B3
to keep an eye on my time
still over five minutes
still got some tea in My Cup
Knight D7
okay so this unleashes a bishop maybe
trying to maneuver the Knight to the
queen side
but with Knight D7 the knight's going
away from helping defend the black king
now
yeah I'm gonna continue with attack
got my Pawn got my Rook H file got the
bishop this Bishop's going to be very
key Bishop is currently pinning this
Pawn on F7
wow the point takes the pawn
not sure if that's a brave move or a
reckless move
it's a very fine line between bravery
and recklessness
I'm considering playing Rook dg1 but
yeah maybe I will Rook dg1
simply pinning the bishop
and later I can I can take the pawn if I
want
there's something special about
playing an over-the-board game and just
getting a
a very strong attack there's more
satisfaction
OTV compared to online
okay so we see Pawn H4 opponents saving
the pawn
now Bishop H6
I'm gonna show no mercy
now we really see the strength of having
the that open G file for The Rook like
imagine my pong were still on G2 and
then it'd be much harder to orchestrate
any sort of attack
opponents taking a think here but
there's not too many ways to
even try and defend the bishop like
maybe we'll see Queen F6
and so far this um this has been pretty
smooth uh the board's like super
responsive
uh there's really not much lag maybe
there's a small pause between
upon it making the move and lighting up
on the board
but nothing too bad
now if I want I can take the bishop
yeah let's take the bishop
taken with my Bishop
I'm expecting Queen takes Bishop
if Vox tries to Save the Queen
then
I might be much closer I might be mating
much sooner
oh Queen takes F3 okay
looking for the quickest mate here
yeah Bishop
Bishop E5 how about
now there's three legal moves for lock
but there's no legal moves with the
black king
the three illegal moves are as we see
with this queen
Queen uh Queen G4 Queen G3 or queen G2
and I I do hope there is like a lot of
educational value that can be taken from
this game so we saw a very classic
position that can come from panziani
where got the center it seemed like
black had an opening Victory with
doubling my pawns but
um yeah really suffered the consequences
in the early middle game so as my
opponents oh my opponent disconnected
will Auto resign
uh it's cut off here but all the resigns
and
about 10 seconds
I will also say because I'm on my
speedrun account anyone who I beat from
this account will get their rating
refunded so I feel a little bit bad for
my opponents
but the game is over
and yeah I won by abandonment can I show
what will happen Queen G3
I was gonna I was not gonna take the
queen I was gonna play Queen G5
check forcing Queen takes V5
and then Rook takes G5 checkmates
and then we then we get the the cool
lighting effects
so anyway I hope you guys enjoyed the
game uh again links below if you want to
check out chess up and get aboard for
yourself let me know your thoughts and
I'll see you guys in the next video